("Cat & Mouse Fight" by Swag House Mafia)
- [Narrator] Birches, birches, birches.
Even more birches.
Yes, thousands of birches everywhere.
What is it about Umeå and
its passion for birch trees?
- (speaks in Swedish)
- [Narrator] And the residents of Umeå,
they use the birch for
just about everything.
They use them for art,
they are painted on art,
they become furniture, decorate houses,
they color fabrics,
make medicine of birch,
glue and soaps, they make
tea and mixed drinks.
Wait, what?
Is that right?
Drink birch?
- (speaks in Swedish)
- [Narrator] Even in the winter,
when the birches are bare and ugly,
they brighten up the town
but then, you have to go
indoors to peak at them.
But why is everyone in
Umeå so crazy for birches?
Given that it's winter most of year,
wouldn't pines have been
a more natural choice?
- (speaks in Swedish)
- [Narrator] Okay, time for
a trip back into history.
Let's rewind to Umeå in 1888.
Back then, the whole town was,
more or less, built of wood.
On June 25th, a fire broke
out in the city's brewery.
Gale force winds caused the fire to spread
and grow to a disastrous size.
The whole town burnt down.
- (speaks in Swedish)
- [Narrator] That sounds pretty brilliant,
does it actually work?
- (speaks in Swedish)
- [Narrator] Not everyone
is impressed by these trees.
(sneeze)
Lots of residents here
suffer from pollen allergies,
some so strong that they
can't bare to go outside
for parts of the year.
So, how do locals coexist
with their city's symbol?
Is there a solution to this problem?
- (speaks in Swedish)
- [Narrator] Do you dare trust the tea?
Seems like it's worth a
visit to find out yourself.